hi my name is Laura I have been working
since I was 13 and I had probably
between 15 and 20 odd jobs in my life
thus far since college I have worked as
a carpenter as a legal secretary a
Christmas elf at bloomingdales
we would hide them in dark corners of
the cavernous apartment scare the guests
and then we would see ourselves out
normally when I do zombie makeup on a
film set I'll be working between 12 and
14 hours and making maximum 300 a day
this was a thousand-dollar gig that was
less than four hours of my time film
school unlike medical school or law
school there's no real guarantee of a
job after school so a lot of people are
taking out 250 thousand dollars worth of
loans and when they graduate they may
not be able to support themselves in
this field as I get older it gets a
little bit more frustrating to do odd
jobs i do feel like i have a skill set
that should pay me adequately in my
field but unfortunately that's not the
way it works in the arts i'm hoping at
one point i can make a living only doing
what I love to do I've never regretted
being an artist mostly because i can't
really conceive of being able to do
anything else
you